all right be I'm taking you to school oh
they're trying to merge
idiots oh we're fine just got to hit
this
ramp so I was saying I'm actually a
great driver so today we're looking at
other bad drivers not me of course you
may have seen these pop up in your feed
Ryan Gosling from Drive meme it's just
random Dash footage but the thing about
it it's that you never know what you're
going to get people are crazy I realize
there's just ungodly amount of these
footage in Indianapolis an SUV
approaches a red light at an
intersection as a pedestrian enters the
crosswalk typical pedestrians messing
everything
up
Jesus
Christ where the [__] did that come from
hey anyone drop
this does this belong to anyone if you
felt bad for laughing at the white car
in the first scene you have a good heart
yeah I felt bad
actually come on you know they're fine
in these footage right they're fine
see see no one was harmed they said
it there he is totally fine I'm just
going to make a left turn without
looking a
sh they're fine they're fine it's okay
to laugh stop pretending I'll show you
how good I am at parking later I think
that's really my
specialty world's worst drivers
are they in
Russia
Jesus is that common in Russia yeah what
a terrible driver how did they not Dodge
those trees what an idiot I would have
[Music]
just out of there this is what it's like
to browse the internet without using
nordvpn that's right this video is
sponsored by nordvpn there's people
everywhere trying to attack you you the
internet gets
restricted but somehow I'm making it
through this you're more unsafe without
it get out way I'm using
nordvp by using a
nordvp you can always make sure that
you're protected when browsing online
and don't end up like this maybe you
guys are planning some trips this
year and you whenever you buy airline t
tickets you know they store they store
your information and they might change
the
prices and there's different prices
depending on where on the planet they
you are so don't get price discriminated
just use n VPN
connect whoa whoa they're going against
traffic and it's that
easy always make sure you get the best
price it's practically just man you're
making money by buying
nordvpn I'm Dy take advantage of
nordvpn's New Year deal right now you
get a 2-year plan you get a huge
discount huge plus 4
months additional for free when you use
my link you get the best deal and only
then you get the offer so go to
nordvpn.com SL PewDiePie it's risk it's
risk-free with nor vpn.com come money
back guarantee try it out for 30 days
see if you like it then you can change
your mind ah like I should have that's
nordvpn.com
PewDiePie get the best deal on the
internet risk-free thank you nordvpn for
sponsoring this
video
oh no
accident how is this worst driver there
was no accident anything that was clutch
as hell look at that people do this to
me all the time they expect me to stop
it's like no I wish I was a truck so I
just had an excuse to run into them I
don't wish that
actually but if I ever drive a truck so
that's oh my God oh my God I know I
shouldn't be laughing they're
traumatized but I feel like I'm part of
it all right let's switch over to
Australia there's Australian uh dash cam
owners of Australia appar has a YouTube
[Music]
channel yeah you [__]
mom took the words out of my mouth I
wish Kim was here he could confirm if
they sound like
that yeah yeah no no you can't hon that
go on do it I bet you'd enjoy it me
Jesus should have looked
left oh [__] come
on that's what you get just completely
[__] on oh now you're going back okay
great the reaction
time
your husband's a little
[__] go go go go go go go go go I love
having this wheel here this is so much
fun I feel like when you give the kid at
a controller and they're not playing
customer says there's no spare
tire okay what is it underneath the
car
I can't find it where is
it for seeing an idiot all right I'm
going to skip some Jesus yep that's why
I moved oh boy that's why that's why I
moved my yeah what do you think I would
let that guy hit me from behind I don't
know sometimes when people you know
switch Lane really quick in front of you
and you're moving and then there's a
stopped car you know that could cause an
accident but I don't think that was the
case there a [__] oh no oh [__] bro why
bro you can't park
there yeah I'm ready back up be check
this [__] out be I'm just going to be
late
oh yeah I'm back up
more God
damn
oh oh if just once I could see something
like that why do he stop you're on a
fuel there I've seen this one it's a
classic
so he vehicle 1039 1039 JSO he catches
the cop
mph and a 15 M hour
Zone yeah busted what do you got to say
for yourself how you doing problem 36
mph and 15 M hour Zone what's the
problem officer oh wait that's me I
mean this oh he was hitting his brakes
okay all right all
[Music]
right all right I don't want to cause an
accident need to get
off I'm in the I'm on the side he's just
bust
man love it I love it hero although you
know people do that in UK it's really
irritating I mean I I didn't do it
because I didn't do it but I got a
ladder from like a random person be like
we caught you speeding I'm like is it a
ticket no it's just some guy I mean this
didn't happen to me just imagining the
scenario and uh yeah I was like what am
I going to do sorry get a hobby okay
don't bu me I didn't do anything by the
way this never happened I'm a great
driver check this [__] out okay okay
stop sign it didn't
stop what an
idiot okay I guess we're going
[Music]
here
whoa shortcut all right well anyway you
see my point you see my point Ohio state
senator using Zoom background of his
home office while driving debating a
bill for harsher penalties for
distracting
driving that can't be real no he's in
his living room what's the I don't get
it I was wear Cella in my house you
never know what's going to hate you
let's switch it up a bit let's look at
people parking cuz that's my forte and
people are just bad at parking man look
at this dude
he's like I'm doing the same move over
and over again it doesn't
work come on you can do
it no they did not try to push the car
they got to push harder
idiots he you got go left no [__] way
he just park like
that oh that was beautiful parking
that's just so something about it I
don't know what it is let's see some
other good ones this looks like it's in
China uh I keep hearing great things
about Chinese
drivers
uhhuh that's a good parking he's right
between the lines oh he's adjusting
oh all right he made some new parking
space that's great how considerate uh
we're backing China great
how do you end up like this oh God you
got to push the car you just got to go
ahead and push the
car oh she did oh we in Russia now great
fesia no that can't be
[Laughter]
[Music]
real
that can't be real that can't be real he
realized he missed the exits we've all
been there [__] now I got to had like at
least 50 Jesus Christ now is he going to
turn around he's just going to back up
that's a oh God he's actually doing
it this is in
Europe yeah I'll probably back up too if
I see someone go against traffic just
like get out of my
way hell yeah hell yeah Giga Chad
H you didn't miss it by a
little is he going to make it oh my
[__] God that's so
dangerous nailed day
yeah I love that Volvo driver mstic one
for another typical Volvo
drivers they got no idea what's going on
oh sh B oh he's fine
okay no way
no you're idiot what are you doing Volo
rers
fools
like I'm just
on whoa he's lucky that didn't flip over
drive off to the sunset through the
ocean this kind of stuff would happen a
lot in UK cuz it rains all the
time you just got to commit you know no
it stopped
working what an
idiot oh they got got it back all right
we just got to clear some water
no
[Music]
jeez is that a
Tesla all right Tesla
Maiden
Mercedes looks all
right
nope yeah that's the way to do it can't
go no Mini Cooper son
look how much water is in the side that
car that sabaru
KIA Ford I can't see it's
Kia no
way the balls I'm going after the mini
and then still [__] it up an off-road
vehicle's got to make it
right Land Rover yeah yeah yeah
is that a
to come on to
son
ah ah come on UK a country that rains in
all the time should we do something
about it no [__] no I remember when my
house flooded one time in UK and the guy
was just like I don't know I'm like cool
thank you all right I'll show you guys
how good I am at parking really quick
maybe we go to a
smash repairs no tires really oh Motel
okay that's
good Jesus what an idiot oh my God
move all right speedrun speedrun
park reverse how do I reverse reverse
there we
go neutral
that's pretty good there we
go
oops ah